And we look quickly and. It was also important for us to have times debate again as women.
For instance are part of a women support group which has been going to seventies and. It's been put.
Important for us to get together and to talk about our own experiences and to reflect and to really encourage
and challenge each other to take steps and be brave and display gap.
And it's been important for the men also to get together and to explore. What have the in the limitations of.
Growing up in the society on them as men. And what did they need to do to open up. The other aspects.
So at times we worked separately and. Then came back together. Much stronger. Both much stronger.
And were able to face each other and times. Work on forgiveness. Yeah. That was important.
But it's not a problem with people who accept the necessity for him in this times where and
when it might have been perceived as a threat. But it's. It's aimed a lot more can happen.
By working together and surely separately. And then coming back together and. Mating is. As a calls.
Rather than sort of hammering it at on an individual basis. Somehow that so slow a path. Here.
So the women's movement has been a really important strand. I think in the growing in changing. And bringing.
Aquarius to fruition. Here. Will get. You know. I see in these. Here. Allan andrea. Who had the default.
But very much part of the aquarius generation i suppose i was a radical young senior tutor in psychology at the car uni
at the time of the festival and. It was all of that stuff was in the air about.
About leaving the cities about my world instead of the one that was producing the vietnam war and the oil crisis
and the.
And what we thought was the you know the the decline in the whole quality of life in the absence of any kind of
spiritual magic dimension in life. In the lives of their parents i suppose. And after the aquarius.
Festival it became obvious that some people were actually leaving the cities leaving the universities.
Going up to leave in the way that we were all. Starting to talk about. And the beginning of not in seventy five.
I already knew some.
Some friends who had already come up to to leave that name and had lifted jobs
and so i got to be friends got to be part of a group who were interested in buying a huge area of land and.
A little bit west of newman where we could have a virtually self-sufficient. Place. Almost a self sufficient. Town.
And basically about twenty five shareholders twenty five groups. Some a couple some with single people.
Bought six hundred thousand acres of land out in the heat of the clarence river and a couple of as waste of human.
Yeah. Carol we knew it was.
It's really a wilderness it's the headwaters of the plants
and the cataract rivers so it's completely mountainous with some tiny little bits of flat land perfectly suited to it
to a commune for lots of people to live on because it's magic country. It's.
Miles of literally miles of these rivers because they they snake around all the mountains and.
Magic mushrooms grew there in profusion. And you couldn't. Very much so it looked like a lot of hard work.
It was just really interesting country. It was not. Hundreds of miles away but on the. And he sort of.
Seventy kilometers or so away from the coast. And we thought that. What we do is go. Move up there and have a.
Be able to to make a truly self-sufficient sort of law start with some of the heartache.
Things like peace founding and. Organic agriculture that were things studied in the in the new ideas.
Institutions in america.
We were a mixed group and basically the group started with a group called design farm from listeners trailer.
Which was a core group of. A couple of architects and a couple of engineers who tended to to build and design.
Whole mining towns in witness tried including putting in the water supply and. The electricity supply power supply and.
Roads and. All that sort of thing and they found they work out to a lot of kind of.
People who would like to work for six or nine months intensively but one nine to five. So the people.
That was a group got together together with them. And i was in western australia and.
And the other half of the group came from sydney. We are a mixed bunch of.
I was an academic there were some musicians and. Just.
Generally people who are interested in creating our own lifestyle i suppose and and.
You know living the way that we were. We were thinking. Challenging the existing andi's of family and. Economy and.
The whole business of.
Having an older generation who are conscripting is to go to war was we didn't believe in against.
You know the threat of.
So-called threat of communism when we had thought that we needed a lot more communality in their lives
and a lot more sharing in the lovelace. Just working to increase. Money. And we already had plenty. In our member.
Just before we came up. But before we left the city. We had a draft dodgers.
Sort of organization going that we had hired people who'd already been conscripted in the lottery.
And we brought you have to sink as the russian poet. To speak at new south wales university. Which was a real.
Really thawing in the face of a government who was saying. The conscripting is to thought.
You know the the communist system in. You know let me set the stage it. Was by stunnel. Principles.
You know ideas from living.
Communally
and nonviolently as the american indians did ideas from the eastern religions which were starting to to embrace and to.
Understand and follow at that time a lot of ideas about having.
Magic as well as a spiritual dimension in their lives from in such way psychedelic drugs. But very much.
I think very much it was just an adventure. Very much. Life in the city. He was.
Was quite comfortable the country was will see. It was easy to get scholarships.
To go to university it was easy to be paid to do research on social sciences and.
How the family was breaking down and when you need a personal and family structures and economic structures
when needed and. We just saw the opportunity to go out and start doing instead of just talking about it.
A member of the couple of years before i left i organized a course called a family in the modern world in the.
Behavioral sciences school with contributions from sociologists and psychologists and. And answer politest. And after.
Having all sorts of people speak in that course including people who'd come up and leave the name and already.
It was just time for any of us who could to to get up and actually do it and not just talk about and theorize about it.
Well in the early days in the early years it was wonderful it was a it was a celebration it was an adventure it was
found it was very creative. We were a buzz with talk about how to build dams and.
Dodecahedron zoo and how to put on water supplies from hydraulic rams which didn't they do any.
Electricity and all sorts of alternative ways of. Refrigeration and. Fish farming and.
Agriculture that didn't they'd chemicals and. Didn't abuse animals and.
New forms of relationships and looking at the children and their own music and. Just really.
All facets of life it was fascinating it was energetic it was very colorful and. We use.
We wouldn't touch alcohol because that was the drug of the older generation.
We smoked a lot of it in a very celebratory sort of.
Happy way rather than trying to watch as it was that in any scenes that was really the last thing that any of us would
would want to do that. Studies because life was so full of possibilities and.
Hasn't done is to be built in water supplies to be put on and.
New ways of living in thinking to be found in your allegiance to explore. New aspects of the.
The internal world through. Through psychedelics and so on and. I remember.
Saturday mornings in the promenade mornings where everyone would come from there. From their wake of.
Trying to get a new lifestyle going to the way they colors and.
The ride up and down and talk to one another in the shannon market and a couple of the.
Was that was the first market and that was them. The monthly. Get together with people from other villages and.
People too far away to see in the menards saturday mornings.
The best thing about the shannon markets was coffee because we all. We're all the reason the city folks and that.
That was probably a really important thing in our lives.
Care when your experiment was a bit different to the neiman one in that it was so isolated and such a vast area.
And it really needed.
Probably a dozen people families to be there at once in order to get such a big place going to to do something about
the river as far as supplying. Regular water and. Accommodation and. We would only go to town once a week.
And the difficulty with kara we knew is that we somehow just didn't get that many people coming at once.
That was the only downside otherwise it was. It was quite wonderful to be a long way away from home and.
And in a very special and vast place. They didn't. I didn't because. I think mainly because not all twenty.
Shareholders came over and made it go
and we would have needed that many moments that many to do the sorts of projects that we wanted to.
And we needed everybody to bring all of the capital and. All of the time. To the place and get it going and.
When we came to care we knew and
when we bought it it looked like the quality of life in the cities was declining faily rapidly there was also an oil
crisis on when. For some reason the i picked countries. Cut their supplies because they thought that this.
They supply of oil was quite finite and limited. And now they don't think that anymore. So they produce more.
But at that time.
They were some of the agency in finding alternative ways of life that didn't depend on fossil fuels and.
Limited resources. But of that concurrently with not in seventy five seventy six when we went up the.
The oil across a sort of. Past the past over and. Things in the cities. Started to get gradually better.
And somehow not enough people were really willing to sell up
and bring all the time in a live resources to care we need to make it. To make it work.
And i think it was such an ambitious project that it needed. All that time and energy and money to to make a go of it.
So it turned out rather than the. Real distant retreat.
And that one stage we had plans of turning it over to the national parks association.
To make a national park of the whole thing. And it's pretty much that man.
We are aiming for a real self-sufficiency were i mean for a place which really could take care and be a complete.
Country. As a self-sufficient country and. For for a group of people.
And we had the idea you had in mind was problems in western australia which was an area of land in western australia
that. Fellow calling for prince rupert.
Took over and he should resign stamps and banknotes and seceded from the commonwealth probably not legally and.
In fact the lawyer who'd been helping him to arrange all that business. Was in contact with a lawyer.
John accidents in the u.k.
In lismore who who we got in contact with and he was the lawyer for kara
when you're so we were thinking along those sorts of lines it was going to be totally self-sufficient. Heartache.
New age. Sort of place. And when that. Skyler of. The new the new world didn't work. Many of us.
Can back to what the others who'd left the cities were doing when prepared to go back to the city but.
We came to nimbin or. Village and places like that where where it was more people intensive and.
Where there was already. And a new culture and. Plenty of music and. Plenty of company and.
New schools read children and.
That became important as we were getting slightly older and we were starting to have kids
and kids were getting to school age. So i left kara when you eventually in came to nimbin and.
Was involved in setting up the newman community school. Just at the time a daughter was turning five. That was.
Here the community school was.
It was set up by sickly john gagan dorothy smith who were two schoolteachers who had worked mainly in.
Independent schools before. Jonathan. Carabiner in north sydney. And. It was a school which was taught.
Completely by parents.
Parents all reach anyone who had the children they had to do
or die a week at the school whether it was taking the kids swimming or teaching something in particular
or maintaining the building or whatever. And a couple of people john and dorothy i'm a sylph did.
About three days a week the. Just just because we wanted to.
We got grants straight away from the commonwealth government. To set up the school and.
The grants continued to hold for the five or six years that i was there and we had about fifty kids from yvette
and five to five to twelve. Just to primary school.
And basically what happens is that the kids were very happy to be there
and thrived there till they were a bit ten years old when they wanted to go to the real school
and have real teachers and wear uniforms them. To all the things that we with from every escaping from. And.
It was wonderful we had sort of formal classes in the mornings in the afternoons we played music and went swimming and.
When bushwalking and exploring and. Visiting found in the back of. Japes and.
Going on we went a lot of excursions all around the country to john allen caves over to the.
Fraser island and we used to just take a couple of.
Company vans and a jeep and take at fifty kids and live self sufficiently and cook and.
It's very strong i think the idea was it just a continuation of. Parenting.
In the school system up to the idea of a bit. And i think it.
It turned out to be most appropriate a really good model we of course thought that we could keep on doing it until
and go through high school with their own school but. The kids voted with their feet and they just.
They didn't want to be taught by their parents after they were. Teen.
And that usually will have a little bit of trouble. In the three months of trouble.
In transition to the public school system and then they after that they did very well. Extremely well.
We had the best part of school probably was the excursions.
They said where we would not be worried about insurance and so on like of the other school teachers would be.
Just take the kids anywhere that was interesting for their education.
The other aspects were really really the music in the face to the dimensions of sort of magic and spirituality and.
In life which was signed that's missing in the city and. Dial really combined.
Right from the beginning we had things called healing festivals where we would all.
On mass go to some place by a river on somebody's property or in the national park somewhere. And it was.
It was like a festival or a bizarre of. Of healing techniques and. Meditation techniques and dancing and music.
And this would be a big blackboard where anyone who could offer anything in the way of.
Skills of the hill thought of meditation or celebration. Would write up. Some time of the day when that would be on.
So i would start off early in the morning. At sunrise with some kind of meditation and.
Continue through the day we would cook communally we'd watch each other as a community would.
And that night would finish off with with music.
In the morning we every morning we'd have a big circle where one sat in a huge circle which might cover.
You know a quarter and i could have land and. We chant and. Hound. And then those who filled in.
Have some sort of a feeling of support would sit in the middle of the circle and.
And then all sorts of things would happen. In the way of a new age healing. Techniques and.
Singing and meditating and channeling in a g.
and Selling and healing faces which you probably have four or five times a year.
Every full moon we had moon dances because the pair of them in so strong in the country.
That you just need to dance to. To get the devils out of the haven celebrate your energy every.
Every time it's full moon. And in between there were a couple times. There was a fight club every monday.
Where people played folk music but it was doing all these things.
To each other with we're shampooing each other's playing music to one another
or building each other's houses of celebrating. Dancing. Cooking and washing.
It was just wonderful to suddenly be part of the tribe and suddenly away from.
Eventually away from the startling sort of nuclear families of the in the fifty's and early sixty's.
Very very much it was an adventure and it was fun. And someone.
People were often asking what are hippies about and we always said. He's have found.
It was a really colorful celebrate three creative adventure.
And when i got a name in these days
and i see what other people call hippies walking along the streets it just isn't the same breed of human being until.
It's some sort of leftover of a real real colorful lie that i think is that i think is now passed and.
And in retrospect. I think it was. Part of a certain. I once life.
Early twenty's basically the use during the twenty's when. When i still think a young person's got no business.
Jumping straight into the mouths of their parents of lift. And where they should be out exploring new ways and.
Celebrating their life in their youth and energy and sexuality and ability to take drugs without being too.
Hurt by them and so on and so on. And it seems very natural for me and for other people now to of.
As we've got all the to gradually go back into the world and to to hopefully have a bit of a dimension of magic
and spirituality in what we do in everyday life as a result of having spent eighteen years.
Being out of the mainstream of society and. Being able to celebrate and be in touch with their inner jian.
Creativity and. Just adventure. Sense of adventure. I suppose in other generations people have had.
New countries to explore. We had that. The insides of their minds to explore and.
And all sorts of possibilities a relationship that.
They were just awful than the in a very comfortable way that people. That our parents were living in in the cities.
So few would be. I mean. What happened to me in the last. It's the last fifty fifty knees. Is that after living on.
Four or five different communes i bought my own piece of property. I bought this property because it was lovely and.
Had some remnants of rainforest on but it was mainly grass and.
The famine next door came haven't talked me into having some cattle on it and showed me how to how to do it and now.
The property breeds hereford cattle which half of which eventually get eaten is made by people including myself and.
And now i'm a psychologist in private practice doing. Medical legal assistance for the system.
Probably four fifths of my former friends. Gone back to back into the world i call it.
In positions of authority and responsibility and so on in a position where i can offer direction and guidance and.
An example to the people. None of us have done that. Really horrified by what's happened and. We look back on our.
Ten years or so of being hippies in a village head of having led the system with. With thinking that we would never of.
Not done that. It was a wonderful thing to do. When the full time of our lives and.
That seemed to be the right thing to do it. That stage of our lives and this thing.
This seems to be the right thing to do now. There are a couple of people who perhaps from our point of view.
Haven't made that transition. And still sort of fighting it out on the streets of newman but.
But i don't have an audience. The more in my mind it just isn't happening anymore.
A lot of the things that we thought we knew and were fighting for. Now become part of the mainstream of society and.
Course that's a good thing. I'm waiting now for my. My daughter's generation. To find.
Find some way of really questioning what's going on with this crazy economic rationalism and absence of jobs
and dependence on jobs and gloom of the present and. Wondering why they aren't finding some new territory of.
Of the world of the mind to start exploring in ways that.
That we didn't i think we've done and are exploring and had our age of doing that and. I'm more than happy to be.
To be back in the world now. I think much strengthened and broadened by by that experience.
It's hard i mean my maybe the answer to that is. Is of. I often wonder whether. I'm often asked whether we lost.
We've lost. Those of us who have written and gone back into the world of. Somehow ditched their ideals but.
My very strong feeling is that that's just. Just part of us now.
Some of us still grow and but some of the still live communally but not many.
And most of those things which we would probably take is the is the real external. Indicators of.
What it was to be we now don't do anymore but. All i can think now is that i feel a real. Richness and.
That bit of magic in spirituality which i don't think i would have had by this time if i had started living in the city
that my peers generation and set up for us. I think it had to do with the whole thing i think it even had to do with.
Sort of. You know exploring through the use of. Psychedelic drugs and.
Just meeting new challenges or something it was very much a turning inward. Now and that is the richness and magic.
Inside you that your mind is not just. Just some sort of capacity to follow an economic rationalist idea and.
Work harder and. Accumulate things and. It's a real happiness sometimes to just be by yourself.
Which we got from from meditation.
I said meditation something you can take any way with you need that in the equipment for. And even. Still the world is.
Permeated with other people trying to sell you things in order to make life interesting or make you healthy
or make you happy and.
Once you've been meditating for a long time you know that the best way to be healthy and happy and.
And to feel magic in the interest is to simply sit down and.
And be peaceful and there's a whole world inside there to look at. I think the fact that we came out of the city.
At that i. Means that we just got a real closeness the night show which. Which we wouldn't have had before.
And in many cases. We've got a love and a closeness to niger which even.
Some of the old families don't have because we had that. The luxury that. The opportunity that.
The joy of being able to walk around and look at it.
With their mind stimulated with good quality marilynn earth cell and.
Well they all families were working had a count of. Pretending they're enjoying very happily. And many of them.
Kind of trained when i retired to move into town in a brick house and spin there.
They dies and they are still club with the walls and floors covered with carpeted the artificial lots of.
The poker machines. You know i look forward to.
To retiring being have a look at the different lights in the countryside
and maybe learning kept to them in watercolors. And returning. In a sense to those lovely hippy days when.
When we had endless time and. And we could see that the world in the mind was endless and.
The even mysterious and so on and. I think that. A lot of the things that we came up he specifically to do.
Like to get away from nuclear families to get away from monogamy to get away from private property
and to guide tribal and and someone really not with that. And in some ways it doesn't matter because they were in the.
In retrospect.
The kind of symptoms of what was wrong and how we felt trapped
and how we feel very one dimensional in their lives in the city. You can. You can.
We found out that you can have a closeness. To each other physical closeness.
Trust that sort of injury and interactive. Life with each other without.